hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a 2020 Chinese thrilling
Musha movie called Tai Chi Hero
in mainland China Yun Ting the leader of
the Asura sect gathers all his followers
to announce important discoveries he
shows the mysterious black Tai Chi box
containing the Asura Elixir inside at
which they believe would give them the
incomparable power to conquer the entire
territory as the followers drink The
Elixir two renowned Thai Chi Fighters
Zhong and Yan interrupt and accuse you
and Ting of giving the fake Elixir to
his followers
shortly after the followers begin to
feel excruciating pain proving that
yunting indeed feeds them with poisonous
liquid Yan suddenly attacks the leader
of the sect with her sword while Zhang
attempts to eliminate the emerging
Asura's guards after that he helps Yan
fight yunting with bare hands and
eventually manages to defeat him with a
Tai Chi power the pair successfully
retrieved the black box and Zhong tells
Yan to bring it to her master as it'll
cause a huge War if it falls into wrong
hands turns out that the battle is not
finished the poison master named Wan
Rings his Bell which turns the dying
followers into zombies
he tries to fight them but eventually
gets infected by the poison and has to
be rescued by masterchu
meanwhile in fushi Village Yan runs in a
hurry to report to the fire dragon
Master about the Asura sect incident she
then hands over the Tai Chi box to him
who seems frightened because he realizes
that the box is fake and immediately
suggests all the villagers leave the
village the fire dragon Master explains
that yunting purposely lets her leave so
that she could lead them into the fushi
village where the real Tai Chi box is
being kept as predicted a group of Asura
Fighters led by yinting arrive at the
Village to seize the real box they
negotiate but the master refuses to give
the box so when Rings his Bell again in
the big fight between Asura sect and
fushi villagers is inevitable realizing
that they cannot win the battle the
master brings Yan to his house and hides
in a room where he reveals that the
Asura's followers have turned into blood
rakshases a type of demon he also
explains to Yan about the origin of the
box once upon a time three Masters
fought together to exterminate blood
rakshases and the sacred scripture was
divided into two one containing Beast
technique and the latter half containing
Immortal Sutra which is kept until today
in the Tai Chi box they decided to burn
all the scripture but unfortunately one
of the Masters sichu Wang had an evil
plan keeping the Beast technique to
himself and burning the fake scripture
to deceive the others afterwards the
master gives the real box to Yan telling
her to bring it to the Dragon Gate sect
to find a man who can open it soon the
Asura sect appears in the room the fire
dragon master has to face all the
fighters alone he manages to give a
tough battle but eventually bow the
leader of heavenly State who is also the
descendant of sichu Wang shows up and
kills the master with his signature
Sword move Master Chu the leader of
Dragon Gate sect tries to remove the
poison from zhong's body with his power
but he is unable to cure him as it's an
unusual poison
ching ching is worried about his
husband's condition but you cannot do
much about it not long after Yan arrives
and tells the master in tears that fushi
Village has been destroyed Master Chu
explains that the immortal Sutra Inside
the Box can't fall to the Asura sect
because the box is indestructible they
must find a spell to open the box he
orders Jong and Yan to find kwailu osani
the only person that can open the box
and destroy the scripture immediately
furthermore Chu mentions that Zhong must
go to master who first before the poison
spreads throughout the body meanwhile it
seems like someone is eavesdropping on
them from outside
a few moments later the village is
ambushed by Asura sect fighters who
ruthlessly Slaughter innocent villagers
inside the house Zhong Yan and ching
ching are forced to flee while master
Chu will buy Time by challenging yunting
in a duel the sword fight ensues with
Master Chu manages to dodge several
slashes from Yen Ting even sometimes he
manages to land some good strikes
towards the Asura's leader unfortunately
yunting plays dirty using this
opportunity to stab the master to death
on the other hand the trio is being
chased by the guard until they are
cornered another battle ensues Zhong is
still able to perform a decent Tai Chi
skill despite his condition getting
worse in the middle of the fight ching
ching is attacked by a guard and ends up
falling off the cliff shortly after Yun
Ting joins the fight and eliminates Yan
with his sword left with no option as
his partner is also killed Zhong becomes
hopeless so he decides to jump with the
black box that night Zhong is found by a
young monk named Gia he finds out that
zhong's still alive and decides to bring
the body with him at the same time
dongjun discovers a lady's body on the
lake meanwhile Baus health is
deteriorating because he already has the
Beast technique scripture in his
possession he must find the Tai Chi box
as soon as possible before it's too late
the following day Zhong who is in a very
weak condition regains his Consciousness
and asks the monk about the butterfly
Valley on their way they come across a
very skilled swords woman called long
they are amazed by how she defeats all
the Asura's Fighters effortlessly back
to the samurai it turns out the lady he
rescued is ching ching however she seems
to have lost her memory Zhang and the
others eventually arrive at the
butterfly Valley where long admits that
her father was killed by the poison
master and she's now seeking Revenge
Asura's Fighters suddenly appear
attacking the trio long and Zhong fight
them while the monk is just watching
from behind a rock like a cheerleader he
then eventually gets hit by a Fighter's
body causing him to fall into a well
Zhong and long decide to follow him they
end up stranded inside an underground
room soon master who appears and
immediately sniffs John's body claiming
that he's familiar with the poison smell
after a long conversation the old man is
willing to cure Zhong but on one
condition that is he must kill the
poison Master Zhang agrees to the term
so master who immediately performs a
healing technique towards his body after
that the poison is fully eradicated and
now Zhong has to fulfill his promise
they then continue their Journey to Find
kwailu osani however John believes that
his wife is still alive thus they decide
to stop in a town for a moment on the
other hand ching ching is getting closer
to dongjun the samurai reveals that he
travels across nations in search of the
best martial arts fighter and then
intends to battle them he mentions Zhong
who is considered one of the best
fighters in China but ching ching seems
clueless about the name back to the trio
the monk accidentally finds a warrant
from Heavenly state which offers a huge
Bounty for John's head after that Zhong
is confronted by the Royal troops they
attempt to arrest him but he manages to
defeat all of them and eventually decide
to leave the city when they Embark Jong
accidentally sees ching ching from a
distance but Gia and long convince him
that she's not her as she gives no
reaction at all towards him in the
forest Jong asks the monk whether he
knows about a man named quailo osani he
admits that kwailu osani is actually his
master which makes Zhong very relieved
shortly after dongjun appears
challenging Zhong in a duel to prove
who's the best in martial arts he
rejects the challenge but the samurai
keeps insisting to fight the man Zhang
promises to fight him after he finishes
with his stuff he asks dongjun about the
girl beside him but the samurai tells
him that her name is Sakura not ching
ching when dong Joon returns to his
he finds a letter revealing that ching
ching has been kidnapped and he must
tell Zhong to bring Thai cheese box to
Heavenly state or they will hurt her
dongjun immediately runs back to the
trio handing Zhong the letter while
telling them that he found ching ching
who lost her memory from the river and
now her life is at risk the next day the
monk leads them to Kuala osani upon
arriving they explain everything to the
master after confirming that zhong's
worthy enough for the spell to unlock
the box he writes the spell on zhong's
Palm the monk decides to stay with his
master so Zhong and long immediately
walk back to the city to rescue ching
ching at some point they stop and Zhang
attempts to open the box with a spell
after the Tai Chi box is successfully
open Yoon Ting suddenly shows up turns
out that long is working for him all
this time
she steals the box and admits that she
has memorized the spell as they leave
Jong is attacked by the fighters but he
manages to defeat all of them easily
long and yunting return to Heavenly
state where they hand over the immortal
Sutra to Bow as he begins to master the
scripture bow orders his subordinates to
defend the place from John
few hours later Zhang arrives at the
palace to save Chang who has regained
her memory after getting her head
knocked earlier as they refuse to
release ching ching Jong decides to
fight the whole Army single-handedly he
manages to defeat all the fighters
without getting injured at all the
poison Master then begins to ring his
Bells again summoning the blood
rakshasses to kill Zhong despite the
zombies being more violent and fast it's
not a big deal for Zhong lastly long and
yunting intervene in the fight as
they're the remaining Fighters even
though it's a two versus one battle
Zhong is still very strong for them and
he manages to defeat them with his
signature Tai Chi move at the same time
dongjun also shows up to rescue ching
ching the poison Master attempts to blow
poisonous powder on him but he blocks
them causing the powder to backfire on
him unfortunately ching ching does not
recognize him anymore so he leaves in
sadness
after a while Bao who is mastered Beast
technique and Immortal Sutra finally
comes out to test his ability Zhong
initially has a hard time fighting him
but later dongjun returns to assist him
the battle continues where Jong and the
samurai take turns to attack Val however
they can't do much as the foe is
significantly stronger compared to them
Zhong suddenly remembers the advice
given from Master kwailu osani then he
performs a yin-yang technique to attack
the leader of heavenly state which
effectively injures him
he eventually dies after realizing that
he's not Immortal yet after that they
get into the palace finding the poison
master who later dies of his own poison
the men subsequently approached ching
ching but she chooses Zhong instead of
the Samurai leaving him in
disappointment months later Zhong and
Dong Joon meet again to prove who's the
best fighter in the world
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching